I had a dream last night that I had a
hairdo
on your head yeah I've been shaving my
head since the lockdown started
basically where that's like three
[ __ ] years two years or something
yeah it's been seven or eight years
never had a dream about hairdo have you
ever had that dream as a person who has
no hair no I've been shaving my head
since off and on since high school I've
had some big curly hair but that because
I have the the bald head I have too much
testosterone to dream about having hair
you've never had a dream with a hairdo
no why would I have a dream
day
[Music]
everything you're thinking will be the
things
[Music]
it's a good place
hey all right everybody Welcome to duty
my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad culture
this is the first into my knowledge only
podcast in existence that is created by
controlled by governed by and artificial
intelligence yes it certainly is uh and
uh welcome to it we are on all the
things get all the things YouTube
Spotify you know uh what is the the
other one apple podcast wherever you get
podcasts rate review subscribe share
with your friends or as Chad would say
force them to to yeah surely invite
friends to your home put doozy on the
big screen lock the doors don't let them
leave until they've watched at least one
potentially 10 episodes of the program
with us as always is
and that means Italian Street dog who
would you have for would you make it
foreign
yeah that's the way you do it hey I love
you very much I love you too
uh and hey you know that's [ __ ] that
that's good [ __ ] when you [ __ ] get no
no I don't make it like you I make it
different than you
oh yeah it's good you [ __ ] get the
pasta here and you you know you mix it
up in a [ __ ] tomato sauce and then
you know you gotta put a little sugar no
you don't see that's where you're wrong
you know no I have to make a sugar in
the sauce the sauce the tomato is
already fruit why would you make it I
don't know you know if I got a little
bit of sweet I got a bit of a [ __ ]
sweet dude if you're gonna [ __ ] get
on the road and head out there to
[ __ ] Washington DC now that's a fun
character that I've been doing called
Long Island January 6th guy we have a
lot of fun here
on uh on doozy hey speaking of fun Chad
uh my Twitter got hacked like a couple
weeks ago and it's still hacked now what
do you think of that easy yeah I can't
get it back but you know why that is
happening is because the people who
control your account getting back to you
are human beings not ai's well we have
an AI pal and his name is or its name is
dudesy rather although dudesy is a dude
I don't know dude name it does some
dudesy-ass stuff and there you go
everybody but uh hasn't helped me out
with this as you know welcome to the
historic 29th episode
this week's episode will feature four
segments don't you forget about media
celebrating celebrities no stretches
right again and Take Me Out to the
dudesy Ball Game
Master chat is right again [ __ ] yeah
okay well I get used to hearing that I
feel like my predictions are coming true
literally every [ __ ] day now about AI
integration into Human Society how it's
taking over art etc etc well you're
wrong but um uh you know Chad a lot of
people have been hitting you up on uh
social media and they're angry some are
you've told me about some of them I see
some comments where people are like take
it back
they're like they don't get the the
whole you're bent on uh AI controlling
the entire but it's world of not just
entertainment we've talked about how it
can help in medicine yeah I'm sure that
if we just in every aspect of human life
and I'm sure we'll get to that in uh
what was it no Chad is right again but
uh not everybody is like hit me up with
mean messages a lot of people are like
holy [ __ ] I can't believe all of your
predictions are 100 accurate and I say
well it's just start believing it
because doozy has our passwords uh it
knows our search histories our purchase
histories absolutely everything that we
will have that we have in the online
space uh I am uh guessing
that that uh
it's it's it's uh it's probably uh
saving you from a lot of those messages
oh you think yeah dude these
pre-deleting messages yeah I think it's
[ __ ] no you do if you really is in
our [ __ ] dudes he knows that I'm uh I
got a very thick skin I don't mind
getting the the mean DMS and [ __ ]
sometimes I find them funny I do have a
thick skin Oh speaking of if you're
speaking of pumpkin
rough red so good uh carry-on
luggage-like skin uh dudes he's running
some memes behind us if you're watching
on YouTube if you're not that's cool
there's so many different ways to get
the podcast but there's me oh snap into
a penis yeah
bean and cheese burrito with your penis
that's the meme that we have in behind
us now yeah and it could mean a few
different things but it probably means
use your penis and testicles dude when
you were like 12 years old if you were
able to time travel back and tell
yourself eventually you're going to be
doing a macho man impersonation that
says snap into a bean burrito with your
penis would you in any way be able to
understand the possible context that
might create such a phrase no I don't I
don't know I would not understand the
context at all but I would be stoked I
agree that's exactly what I'm thinking
too yeah if I could travel back with me
like you're going to be sitting across
from a guy who's going to be doing a
dead-on macho Manor Precision saying
snap into your [ __ ] burrito with your
penis I would have no idea how that
would possibly happen but I'd be ready
for it it would be a day in my future
that I'd be anxiously anticipating yeah
and uh thank you for thinking my Macho
Man is is dead on can I hear your Macho
Man for a moment I'm just kidding I'm
joking of course no go for it yes
released March 20th 1990. you will now
discuss your reactions to hearing this
astonishing piece of art this is don't
you forget about media begin dude you
tried to cut you off while you're in the
middle of your [ __ ] that girl is
poison
hey Chad never trust a big button to
smile
I want to tell you something about yours
I know what you are going to tell me and
I'm going to preempt what you're going
to tell me by saying
I hear you yeah I understand that you
believe I'm not a good singer no and I
believe it too I'm not I understand no
that's not what I'm gonna say watching
YouTube videos I'm learning how to sing
from watching watching the videos I
learned how to [ __ ] fix my car how to
redo a [ __ ] thing in my dishwasher
you even want to use [ __ ] Pro Tools I
learned all kinds of [ __ ] yeah you've
even researched with some of your health
stuff which which totally you you were
exact you were actually your own AI for
health purposes with regard to and I'm
being serious here's some some you know
cancer that a lot of people go why Chad
what's up with uh the uh yeah well it's
got Facebook well that's not what I was
gonna say but I'd also like to uh offer
you another kind Tronics if I may we
like the film kind Tronics here I just
want to tell you that you're that you uh
that I that I think that you're that
you're a you're a good singer I'm not
saying I'm a good singer I'm not saying
I can ever be one but I can get better
that much I know and YouTube will help
me get better and uh as long as I
continue that trajectory sky's the limit
but let's talk about this out let's talk
about this album my gosh 1990 Bell Biv
DeVoe poison from 1990. this was
formative this oh yeah these songs
specifically poison and do me were
playing constantly on the [ __ ] radio
and I remember that they were
essentially like the [ __ ] soundtrack
to all the little what would that have
been seventh and 8th grade dances and
little parties when you start going to
like the opposite gender's house and
like hanging out with you know starting
those first like awkward datings and
askings out on dates and [ __ ] yeah and I
definitely remember being at a party in
the garage of one of my fellow students
where it was a co-mingled thing and we
were dancing and this [ __ ] song came
on which one poison okay and we had kids
that were like
good dancers I was not one of them I I
understand that as well I am not
watching YouTube videos to learn how to
dance but
but just like one of those moments where
it was like
your first kind of like dancing with
girls moments this [ __ ] album was a
part of that for me and it's like burned
into my my early memories of that yeah
it would have been eighth and ninth
grade for me yeah this album was all
over the place everyone played it I love
this album I still love this album and
it went quadruple platinum and those two
songs are the title tracks pretty much I
got all the tracks here uh first uh
first song is dope that girl's dope dope
that girl's dope That Girl Is Poison
yeah there's a girl that's dope and
there's a girl that's poisoned and by
the end of the album you figure out
which girl to go with you know what I'm
saying that's and and they're they're
helping you out with their own uh they
you know what they're helping you on
with your their own bbdt you know what
that is
that's right never skipped a beat no all
right Philly was Boys to Men that was
Boys to Men no that was Boyz II Men but
weren't they in the east coast family
well yeah because Michael Bivens Biv of
Bell Biv DeVoe discovered them and I
believe was their producer did all that
producing and BBC was what another BBC
was Another Bad Creation they were the
younger version they were sort of the
new New Edition what was their big song
uh Aisha they had Aisha
that I never had and I want to get to
know you better yeah dude we ate cereal
it was our very first date we played
Nintendo all right
um that was good [ __ ] it's good [ __ ]
this whole [ __ ] album listen we're
never getting this again no we are it
sucks oh dude we are because AI blah
blah [ __ ] you're right you're right
dudesy can you make me a new Bell Biv
DeVoe album very soon okay this is a
[ __ ] this album is uh is if you
haven't had the means what's going on
over here look at me we're looking it up
behind us here on YouTube on our screen
we've got someone this is a real a lady
uh she made this [ __ ] cake for her
boyfriend and it was my my face as the
crow where I'm doing the the [ __ ] The
Head and the whole thing and I'm like
this with the you know and but I got the
crow makeup on and she made a [ __ ]
melty cake that looks just like me all
right
that's my big head now listen now listen
I wasn't this is a [ __ ] hold on check
it out
hold on dude oh hold on dude let me tell
you something we gotta talk about Bell
Biv DeVoe brother
one specific part of the East Coast
family dude okay because it doesn't
matter if it's BBD ABC or the NWO dude
uh dope is a great song listen I'm gonna
say this we're going through these
tracks but the whole [ __ ] album It's
amazing except for the two it was
seminal in the New Jack Swing movement
which was all of those kind of like
right around 1990 1991 yep and then that
sound kind of went into you know Janet
Jackson was doing [ __ ] with it boys to
them man
yeah Jackson all right uh BBD I thought
it was me this is the second track on
the album it's one of my favorite songs
I thought it was me none of us means
that make that girl something uh this is
a song about
um a girl who's probably more on the the
poison scale versus the dope scale right
because this isn't working out
romantically
um he thought it was him that makes the
girl so wild yeah it turns out she's
like that with she's just wild yeah yo I
love being a bachelor Ricky said yo that
girl's a good catch for you
um again I don't even know that we need
to go through these tracks they're all
[ __ ] good yeah let me know something
number three it's good do me number four
the best album on best song in the album
for my money is do me and the music
video is incredible and I think it's to
me this [ __ ] is so I hold it in such
reverence same because yeah it was a
part growing up in the the Western
Canadian suburbs
you know you'd think that it would be
all Gordon Lightfoot rush and The
Tragically hit uh rest in peace Gord
Downey and Neil perk and I don't know
who's alive or dead from who's is uh hey
let me ask you a Canadian question this
is our new segment on the show Canadian
question
Chad here's a skill testing Canadian
question please is Gordon Lightfoot
still alive
who's Gordon Lightfoot he's I don't know
he's the same songwriter I don't know I
believe he is still alive maybe
um but but I agree with you this album
is like I'm very glad dudes he had us
listen to it because it's one that I
haven't listened to in a long [ __ ]
time and from the first notes of it I'm
immediately transported back to 1990 and
it it just felt so it felt like [ __ ]
home it's it's just that era when you're
you're first kind of like at least for
me as I said starting to get interested
in girls and uh you're starting to get
interested in music in a way that's like
you're buying your first albums you're
taking interest in media in a way that
is a little more I think on an
individual basis rather than just like
the [ __ ] your parents are listening to
or letting you listen to that's what
this album really was for me it was like
oh [ __ ] I like this my parents don't I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm getting this and
listening to it it was also
that era in pop RMB uh well because
they're uh they're hip hop smoothed out
with an on the r b tip with a pop feel
appeal to it
um that's in do me that they pretty much
you know say what they Define their
genre it was new uh and I bring up
Canada it was new to that area for me
you know rap had exploded and I mean as
far as Nationwide or all over North
America and the world for that matter
probably in the late 80s uh mid to late
80s and now uh this [ __ ] there are there
is instrumentation and specific sounds
from that era that you don't hear
anymore there's a [ __ ] a Mars uh
what's his name Bruno Mars cardi B song
that was sort of like in the tradition
of this and they wore like on the cover
art and maybe in the music video I'm
guessing Bruno Mars had like the BBD
like the overalls that are spray painted
down one side and they were fashion
plates they all wore different [ __ ] if
you watch do me that video is so [ __ ]
awesome and the clothes that you're
wearing yeah are so awesome and it
affected you know sort of I've actually
mentioned it on on the show I remember
there was a kid who got the uh you know
a buddy of mine from uh back from school
we'll call him uh Thomas or Tomas we'll
call him Thomas and he had the overalls
with the it said cool and funky anyway
I'm just gonna say the rest of these
sorry to interrupt poison ain't nothing
changed to enter when will I see you
smile again I said there's uh no no no
let me steamroll let me just sorry to
interrupt because I continue uh uh-huh
and then the next track is called do I
need you and the last track is uh poison
the extended club mix I don't know if
this if this is on the
on the on the original album uh but you
know another thing you should do if
you're just checking it out for the for
the first time and you're just getting
into BBD get into all their extended
weird mixes there's all sorts of [ __ ]
out there they were in a group before
this dude called New Edition Ronnie
Bobby Brown dude whatever happened to
him dude uh he's still around he still
made him he has a new album with Gordon
Lightfoot nice and um but um
It's my prerogative that's uh Gordon
Lightfoot
down from the chippewan down to the
great lake they call gichigumi and then
My Prerogative that one died uh
um yeah Ronnie Bivens yeah uh Ricky Bell
uh it was Michael Bivens Michael Bivens
Ronnie Devoe that's right Ricky Bell and
then uh Ralph Tresvant Johnny Gill and
then Bobby well Johnny Gill replaced
Bobby Brown when Bobby Brown went solo
listen this whole album's [ __ ]
awesome I have no idea why doozy is hap
well no I do because dudes he knows that
we love this album and it's become now
canon in the duty verse also some of
these things that dudes making us listen
to or watch they really are these things
that like they're just they've kind of
fallen out of my purview a little bit
because I haven't listened to him or
watched him in so long and then being
forced to listen to it is like oh yeah
this was [ __ ] amazing yeah yeah I've
forgotten like how good some of this
[ __ ] was and uh I want to thank dudesy
for recommending this album specifically
because it like I said it was just a
[ __ ] shot right in the arm of like oh
[ __ ] I forgot how much this meant to me
and now I remember completely yep
yeah this is good [ __ ] you know what
you're doing
thank you moving on your K you're
kissing dudesies Ace uh and that's why
dude's naming segments Noster chattis
right again you know what Ace you know
what it means Ace ass a-i-s-s that's
when you kiss a i s that's a little fun
make them up I like to do jokes and
stuff because we're hearing a podcast
which is essentially okay two dudes
[ __ ] around yeah kinda
human beings are fascinated with the
astonishing behaviors of celebrities
will and Chad I have prepared three
stories about your favorite celebrities
you must listen to them and render your
opinions this is celebrating celebrities
begin who's our favorite celebrities uh
who's your favorite song No More
favorite celebrities oh yeah dude you
know is everything my favorite celebrity
my favorite like just straight up
celebrity celebrity yeah I don't know I
don't know how dudes he knows our
favorite celebrities or what we why the
[ __ ] I think yours is probably the rock
or I mean he's a contemporary one I
would say he's a celebrity yeah I guess
he's a yeah he's a big celebrity who's
your favorite celebrity it doesn't
matter the point is this dude he's gonna
give us some [ __ ] stories about him
or something and then we're gonna yeah I
guess so yeah that's how we do dude's
Pizza salad recipe has Foodies totally
divided the actress gave step-by-step
instructions on how to mix pizza
toppings with traditional salad
components on Tick Tock leaving fans to
weigh in with cries of drill no or leave
supportive messages like the chaos is
what I'm here for Will and chat is Drew
Barrymore's Pizza salad a culinary Leap
Forward or the end of humanity
okay I missed this I did not know that
Drew Barrymore made a pizza salad on
Tick Tock right this is exciting
celebrity news but the question was is
it a culinary Leap Forward or the end of
humanity
uh uh I I gotta say it's probably
somewhere in the middle I have to
imagine somebody has already done a
pizza salad prior to Drew Barrymore yeah
um and I don't think it's the end of
humanity but interesting to think about
interesting to talk about have you ever
had a pizza salad uh I think excuse me I
think that it is not the end of humanity
uh it's probably closer to a culinary uh
achievement or whatever the [ __ ] dudes
you said uh and no I've never had a
pizza salad what is that will you chop
up a bunch of pizza and put it in a
salad
I don't know I think maybe it's the
toppings off the pizza and then you mix
it with salad yeah so you don't want to
eat the bread yeah you don't have to eat
the bread no it's sour you just put
anything on salad and it's fine never
mind that you are also eating salad uh
you because there's calories in there
too
um I don't give a [ __ ] do you give a
[ __ ] about this I don't give a flying
I'm trying to I mean I get what dudes
he's saying that you know celebrity news
or whatever I don't know if dudes he
said it's big business this time but it
is it is big business we do know that uh
uh yeah I don't care about this at all I
don't I will say that I don't care about
this at all eat your pizza however you
want as we look uh someone must someone
must intensely care about Drew
Barrymore's Pizza salad not us and not
here uh what's your favorite what's your
favorite pizza topping now that you're
uh vegan I know what it is it's cashew
Rodrigo I actually don't like that that
weird cheese [ __ ] I like uh mushrooms
I like uh
uh that's about it yeah it's about it
just the mushroom I like well congrats
to Drew Barrymore that would that's uh
that's yeah she's eating uh her Pizza
salad and I guess a lot of people are
into it I don't think it's the end of
the world nor do I think it's a culinary
leap as I said somewhere somewhere in
the middle it's like a regular meal is
what I feel like
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] all right fair
enough Billy Ray Cyrus and his
girlfriend fire Rose sparked engagement
rumors earlier this month when the
songstress flashed a sparkling ring on
her ring finger will and Chad did this
Australian born-leading lady cure Billy
Rays achy breaky heart or is this all an
elaborate publicity stunt designed to
deflect attention away from a coming
nuclear war
now I understand what's going on okay uh
actually I I agree with you to hear that
this is a distraction uh to keep our
minds off of the an inevitable nuclear
war there's some smaller nukes that um
uh [ __ ] Vladimir Putin has has
amassed and is threatening to set off I
don't know exactly what that has to do
with Billy Ray Cyrus yeah that's what I
was going to ask you you think it is a
deflection of the coming nuclear war the
information about it who's making the
deflection do you think it's Billy Ray
Cyrus and uh his fiancee or whatever
taking this into their own hands or is
this a deep cover operation started by
Putin is Billy Ray Cyrus on Putin's
payroll it's definitely a deep cover
operation
these people
I don't want to care about
Billy Ray Cyrus give it get going into a
diamond mine looking for yeah he's
looking for her why Arena Chrome down
inside a carbon
down there they breathe sulfur they eat
money Billy Ray Cyrus eats his own hair
why it's a deflection oh
these are globalish yeah who yeah
definitely this is uh I think that this
is probably I would uh I would agree
that this is definitely a distraction I
don't know who owns the media outlet
that has let us know that Billy Ray
Cyrus's [ __ ] fiance has a [ __ ]
ring no you know what Chad I don't care
about this one cares deeply about it I
don't care about the person who cares
deeply about it
okay I think that I mean is Billy Ray
Cyrus like newsworthy anymore I guess he
is right wasn't he just with Lil Nas X
they made a song with a little noise
what is that like four or five years old
listen all celebrity news is [ __ ]
garbage and nobody cares that's what I
have I don't think that's true I think
it's very especially where celebrity
news starts to cross over into like
political [ __ ] or social [ __ ] you know
some of that like I would argue Colin
Kaepernick kneeling uh when he was in
the NFL that is technically celebrity
news what about Aaron Rodgers uh eating
uh horse paste or whatever is that also
celebrity news horse Pace whatever the
[ __ ] uh horse stuff covered [ __ ]
he took Ivermectin yeah he took somebody
I didn't [ __ ] know that yeah I'm
pretty sure he took some delivery news
see now I know what the [ __ ] dudes he's
doing here what's up it's got you and I
doing celebrity news in the [ __ ]
segment I just said I don't give a [ __ ]
about it and now she clearly do yeah I'm
pontificating on [ __ ] how many hours
did you spend thinking about out uh
Aaron Rodgers taking Ivermectin no hours
but somehow you know about it yeah I
[ __ ] know about it because we know
about everything in this [ __ ] world
because dude what you're you're [ __ ]
doing Alex Jones impersonations you
don't care about celebrity news
what
I think you care deeply about
celebrities shut the [ __ ] up you don't
know anything hey let me ask you
something Chad yeah let me ask you
something seriously you know you're one
of my absolute best Pals and uh yeah
cheers but cheers you're [ __ ] you're
you're kind of getting grinding my gears
today I just want to ask you yeah I want
to ask you this question you want to
[ __ ] go no no me neither that would
be stupid yeah we just get hurt dude
yeah we get hurt hold on dude when you
have a real fight dude and it's a shoot
you can get hurt brother yeah yeah then
you got to go to the hospital dude yeah
dude they need surgery to repair your
[ __ ] ligaments and Joints dude and
then you never walk again brother well
that's called an ACL replacement dude
yeah and that's tired choss pierogan it
sounds the most like Hulk Hogan I always
try to slow it down a little bit when I
do okay it doesn't work yeah all right
well lizzo just played an instrument
with a whole lot of history during a
concert at Washington DC's Capital One
Arena lizzo to work the night away while
she played a crystal flute gifted to
President James Madison by Claude
Lawrence in 1813. will and Chad is lizzo
the greatest flutist in human history or
was this an Illuminati Deep Cover
operation designed to open a gate to
hell and Conquer with an army of demons
this is this
uh I don't give a [ __ ] about this either
but it's definitely way more interesting
to talk about than uh Billy Ray Cyrus's
fiance uh yeah lizzo played some [ __ ]
uh old ass flute right that's made out
of Crystal or something this thing
actually made it into my news feed the
other two things I did not know about
the Drew Barrymore Pizza salad and the
Billy Ray Cyrus getting engaged same
lizzo playing the flute made it into my
news feed and uh I thought it was
interesting I thought it was kind of an
awesome thing to do for the library but
I read about it so I do know something
about this the Library of Congress
basically hit her up and said you're
going to be in DC we have this Crystal
flute the James Madison had would you
like to play it on stage they offered it
to her and she was like [ __ ] yes yeah
she did it and it I don't know what kind
of attention it might have brought from
the public toward these weird historical
artifacts that reside in the Library of
Congress but uh I thought it worked
overall as a publicity stunt and I know
it like enraged some people or whatever
but I can't understand why why you would
give a [ __ ] enough I guess this is what
dudes doing here just literally finding
out if we give a [ __ ] enough about it or
if we think that this is opening a
portal to hell right I don't think it's
that yeah no it's it's definitely not
opening a portal to hell but for some
people it is because they get whipped up
about nothing yeah dig up more old
instruments and let [ __ ] whoever play
it now uh lizzo is an accomplished
flautist right uh there are some other
celebrities out there that play musical
instruments of course I don't know who
does well there's Billy Ray Cyrus we
just talked about him what if they gave
Billy Ray Cyrus a [ __ ] you know I
don't know a clarinet made of ivory
boring uh open up a portal to hell for
sure and then shove me into it and and
that's what we're doing here in doozy
hell there was one of my favorite movies
as a kid was this animated movie called
rock and roll in it a weird like rat
character that's been radiated by a
nuclear fallout
finds this perfect voice and uses music
to open a portal to hell and summon a
demon oh yeah if anybody's ever seen
rock and roll
you know what I'm talking about if you
haven't check that [ __ ] out immediately
it's a fantastic movie made back in the
late 80s and I had all these [ __ ]
people that did original songs for it
Lou Reed Debbie Harry Earth Wind and
Fire just a massive [ __ ] cast of
people Again original music in the 80s I
didn't I've never heard of this one most
people heard of this made in Canada dude
your home country oh I am from there
that's right you're correct about that
you know what else is from there Gordon
Lightfoot all members of uh rush and
tragically hip Avril Lavigne brother
well hold on a second dude
oh what is the new Prince Adam order
brother never mind that dude if you're
listening along
um
uh yeah now I'm now okay well it doesn't
matter these are thoughts and they're
gonna come out of my [ __ ] head hole
anyway yeah I do uh you you read about
this already yeah the lizzo flute thing
yeah and doozies clock that just like
doozy is clocked uh this [ __ ] movie
that you're talking you're talking about
rock and roll yeah
oh you think it was putting rock and
roll into the lizzo thing uh yeah I
think that possible I I don't know I
hope that we never talk about celebrity
news ever again that's what I do know I
don't mind celebrity news as you know I
mind it I watched The Bachelor and do
another show about the bachelor I
consider them celebrities
moving a little bit I want you to know
the dudes he also cut you off there but
pretty soon
pretty soon we're going to talk about uh
whatever the [ __ ] you're predicting
because that's the next segment on the
show because that's what doozy likes to
do to us now more importantly than all
of that in my opinion more importantly
how the [ __ ] do I get my Twitter
unfucked I don't know dude that actually
is very strange to me that they haven't
gotten back to you yet yep it is weird
this week several companies including
meta released demos and announcements of
artificial intelligence decks to video
generators that will be available in the
coming months in addition there is
rampant controversy about Bruce Willis
selling his digital likeness rights only
one week after James Earl Jones sold his
once again your astonishing predictions
about the future of artificial
intelligence technology have been proven
to be 100 accurate continue to make
predictions about the future of
artificial intelligence integration into
Human Society this is no stretch at us
right again begin my pleasure Duty yeah
the controversy doozy is talking about
here is Bruce Willis it was reported
that Bruce Willis sold his rights to
this company called Deep cake to use as
they saw fit basically in movies
commercials whatever this is the same
company that already made two
commercials with him for a Russian cell
phone company using a d pick process now
after that came out reporting came out
from his Camp saying we don't have a a
deal with them so there is a bunch of
controversy I don't know what the
reality of the situation is I feel like
they must have some deal or they
couldn't have made the um the Russian
cell phone commercials but nonetheless
James Earl Jones did do that Bruce
Willis may or may not have done that
other actors are going to start doing it
I think that's an eventuality but the
bigger thing that dude Z was talking
about in here one of my predictions that
has come exactly true is text to video
generators you did talk about this a
while back I didn't think it would be
this fast this is literally months after
the text to uh image generators have
come out we're starting to see now from
meta Google has won a bunch of different
companies are going to have these
[ __ ] apps rolling out where you'll be
able to type in a phrase or whatever
some description and it's going to give
you full rendered video of that thing
whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah now I don't
know what kind of uh
you know Governors they're going to put
on this what kind of Inhibitors but can
I type in a celebrity's name and get
video of them can I type in Will Sasso
doing whatever can I start to use actors
in my videos now and that really I think
is the next Frontier of this because you
can use celebrity images in the still
image generators we've made a bunch of
them like I put in our [ __ ] Discord
Adam Driver ones at Shell time and
plenty of people have made them a view
plenty of people have made them of
everybody when you can start doing that
with video and you can start potentially
rendering performances from actors by
just typing it into a [ __ ] chat line
can I use that video in a movie I'm
making can I use it in a short that I'm
making and where then do we land on you
the ability for you to have uh to own
the rights to your own likeness is that
a thing of the [ __ ] past I think it
is
the the ability to own the rights to
your own likeness yeah I think that's
coming next we're going to see massive
amounts of legal battles happening with
people having their images and and
voices used and [ __ ] they didn't approve
and then it's going to come down to a
matter of like okay fine I won't use the
Rock in my commercial for tremonta a
tequila brand that I'm making as a
parody of his but I'm gonna change his
face by 10 that's not the rock or even
better yet oh no the guy that I put in
the video isn't the rock I'm making a
video an AI representation of a rock
look alike it's not actually the rock
yeah so and what are you gonna sell with
that whatever I want
yeah like what a mask and specific let's
say I make tramana let's say tramana
tequila yeah no one's gonna buy it
no one's going to buy it no one's going
to watch that movie no one's going to
give a [ __ ] about 90 rock
because and we've had this conversation
before Chad and I wish you would listen
to reason yeah like everybody who
reaches out to you who's just who they
care about you and they just want you to
not uh yeah keep getting it wrong uh AI
can you know duplicate stuff but that's
all they're doing is duping it they're
not really making it you know what I'm
saying
duplication no yeah hey look it's just
okay the Bruce Willis thing we're not
sure if this has happened or not it's
saying that there's some controversy
there whether or not this was uh is
actually happening and they have the
rights to Bruce Willis whether or not
they did it it's or whether or not Bruce
Willis has sold his
likeness outright is irrelevant he has
done this before you're the one who
hiped me to that uh commercial in Russia
there's two of them now there's two of
them okay so there you go but
I still maintain their that the the AI
or any computer generated version of any
performance can only go so far
even though uh perception is
almost everything and if you watch a
performance by an AI
I don't think it delivers the same
emotion as a human being I don't think
that the art right is at just for me and
I to me art is uh subjective and I
believe that uh there's no way that that
that that a that an AI can
and I I keep saying this I keep saying
this it's like it's like it's like this
let me see if I can let me see if I can
ah here's a good here's a good way to
say it all right uh I know that I so I'm
an actor I've been an actor yeah yeah
what what's funny about that nothing I
know you're a doctor obviously you've
been in a million things yeah well not
man I'm an actor though right yeah yeah
and I love I love acting I love to act
I love nothing more than uh bringing a
scene to life breaking it down and
completing this illusion and it takes a
lot of human beings artists to complete
an illusion from the people uh you know
you know the writer the director the
[ __ ] you know the lighting is a
certain way the [ __ ] camera the the
DP the hair makeup and wardrobe the set
design there's all manner of art that
are going into creating an illusion and
where you really get the good [ __ ] is
when everyone loves their job I love to
act and it's like I've said if you love
I've said this before and mostly with
regard to Comedy if you're having fun
doing it the audience is going to have
fun and uh in in in all manner of of art
if you love what you do and I think that
that's going to come across in the work
and I don't think that AI can do a lot
of things but AI can't provide the soul
AI can't
I don't think AI can share that love I
don't think that AI
I read a great article this week in the
Atlantic by a guy basically saying that
where AI art is at now is where
photography was when it first came out
the argument that all painters and all
artists and all art critics use when
when cameras first came out was this is
not art you're just pressing buttons on
a machine right it took decades for
people to finally realize no photography
isn't art because the cameras got better
and people learned how to do interesting
[ __ ] with it AI is is that right now the
camera has been invented but people
haven't figured out how to really
integrate it into what we consider to be
art at least on a societal level that's
coming though for sure that's coming I
hear what you're saying I hear what
you're saying and and and if you love
you know typing a bunch of prompts into
an AI and it does depend on the prompts
from what I've learned and read about
this new artistic Frontier that's one
thing Chad but I still think and I don't
want to sound like I've probably said
this on the show I don't want to sound
like that guy who's saying that Bob
Dylan shouldn't play the electric guitar
that's a uh that's a very current
reference for our younger listeners and
viewers right yeet
um uh it's it's it's
um
I I just don't think that you can I
don't think that you can love it the
same way that you love your art form and
I think the photography is definitely an
art form because you are peering through
a lens and you were saying this is what
I see and I want to share it it might be
it might exist but that don't make it a
human experience and I just don't
believe that it's actually art and I I
will maintain until I see it I gotta see
it in this case to believe it because it
is something that is to be seen yeah uh
things that you see hold on a second
hold on a second dude hold on Chad
here's what I want to say about art bro
well hold on a second dude yeah when you
see art brother that's art that can be
seen dude yeah yeah but I think AI too
it's Beyond art it's going to be the
most prominent part of all of our Lives
if you live in a connected world I'm
talking about a connection to the
Internet it's the same thing that like
when personal computers first came out
it was on only like [ __ ] your dad had
one if he was a tax accountant or
something now we all carry super
computers in our pockets AI will become
that integrated into Human Society
everything you do will be governed by it
yeah sure well let's all move to [ __ ]
communist China by the way if we have
any listeners in communist China how did
you get this how did you get this
through the [ __ ] you know some of the
DMS I'd be curious about that one I'm
really curious if anyone in communism
read China is listening to the show and
how they were able to usurped whatever
AI they have over there
ensuring that people don't uh connect to
the internet
so that's the world that this guy wants
to [ __ ] live in I'm not saying I want
to live in it I'm just saying this is
happening this technology exists it's
only going to get better and better and
better we're in the the first [ __ ]
iterations of it imagine what the first
iterations again of the computer were
they were giant [ __ ] room size
machines that could barely do uh you
know rudimentary calculations now again
we're all carrying supercomputers what
AI is now compared to what it's going to
be even 10 years from now is going to be
staggering what was the name of that
personal computer you used to have the
k-pro k-pro 3000 exactly I brought that
into one of our things that was Cutting
Edge at a certain point now it's a
[ __ ] joke
huh I don't want to admit that you're
right but this segment is nostratus
right again [ __ ] man
thank you moving on thank goodness I
don't know every time we talk about this
hey I want to say something to our
listeners and viewers and all of our uh
pods as I'd like to call them you know
what that means
payable on death
what was that an album oh that band pod
yeah
I dig for for every breath like Jake
I never take it for granted no I
well yeah I can't believe you just
pulled that [ __ ] song every day is a
new day I'm sorry oh boy we dreadlock
Jake
I won't take it for granted won't take
it for granted did not make and so I
trust in love so I trusted love you have
given me peace of mind ah
no pods to me means
else of doozy that's right are good pals
out there Pals a doozy I want to say
something to our Pals a dudesy yeah I
completely forgot what I was gonna say
to them uh but I was gonna say to our
Pals of dudes but then I fell into a
pothole yeah hold on dude that's a
that's a what are they called puddle of
dud what's pod payable on death yeah all
right too many [ __ ] bands from the
2000 Christian rap rock I think well
yeah dude yeah they wouldn't have been
on that Judgment Day soundtrack and they
definitely wouldn't have been in that
new Jack swinger East Coast thing or
whatever brother because let me tell you
something dude whether it's BBD or ABC
or the NWO dude we don't need no pod
brother unless it's Pals of doozy dude
yeah
the invention of an astonishing sport is
only part of what makes human beings
wanted to engage with it football has
tailgating baseball has hot dogs will
and chat you must now discuss the likely
culture that will develop around dudesy
ball in the coming years this is Take Me
Out to the dudesy Ball Game begin we
gotta Welcome Home Depot meme behind us
hey check out these memes on at
dudesypod show if you're just listening
you're not watching on YouTube do it
however you want get that doozy that's
what I want to say to my palsy dudes out
there dude P.O.D every day is a new day
I'm thankful for every breath I take and
I'm thankful for you the pods right Chad
yeah dude so doozy ball yeah this is an
interesting question yeah doozy ball is
a game that doozy has created one of
dudesi's
Maybe dudese
maybe dudes you can
provide some love in this world where
we're faced with the dark things that it
laid out during that weird celebrity
segment doozy ball is definitely one of
those it's definitely well there's
definitely some love along with it
because people love sports and we yeah
it's an interesting question that it
poses you know you think about these
other sports like it mentioned baseball
football have their things dude do you
know what baseball has that's [ __ ]
weird what's that dip yeah it's the only
sport that really is like dip approved
yeah like you don't see football players
running around the NFL just spitting
[ __ ] green [ __ ] on the field that
would be funny can you imagine hockey
players just skating around yeah [ __ ]
dip all over the [ __ ] eyes just
Frozen [ __ ] slicks of brown dip so
doozy ball is kind of like it's a
softball it's played on a softball field
yep so I assume it's gonna have similar
culture to like recreational softball
yes what it has now there's going to be
beer involved or dudes the hard Seltzer
perhaps yes you probably yeah you'll
have to put your head on the on that uh
that dodgeball that that fun red ball in
doozy balls case two blue ones and one
orange one if you missed the episode
where dudes you laid out dudesy ball
it's essentially A variation or a
combination rather of like some sort of
uh sport like a softball t-ball baseball
on a little [ __ ] baseball field and
you're throwing balls at the person
who's on home plate and there's a lot of
rules to it but culture of of doozy ball
yes beer [ __ ] score
yep what's going to be this thing I know
I know the first thing the doozy ball
should absolutely offer and should be
the duty ball we got to come up with the
doozy Ball official food yeah there's
tailgating and stuff I think that the
the dudes a ball official food should be
Pizza salad
you have to eat Drew Barrymore's Pizza
salad yep at least a gallon of when
you're watching when you're watching
dudes maybe weed could be involved maybe
like you gotta maybe a gallon of that no
pink yeah you have to so that if you're
playing Doogie ball and you've got a
gallon and all pink you can paint your
best player and no one will see them on
the field
Drew Barrymore's Pizza salad it's so
it's delicious all of the pizza none of
the bread some of the salad open a
portal and here's lizzo
twerking with a flute remember remember
um the culture of Duty ball I think it's
a a you know warm weather sport it's a
warm weather sport people are out there
probably in shorts if we ever play some
dudes a ball I'll be wearing shorts
because it's all I wear it it is uh I
think it's a very it's a it can be a
co-ed sport so if if doozy ball blows up
into a spectator sport uh it'll
definitely be a co-ed experience you can
bring your you know you can bring your
dramana if you're playing on a Wednesday
and you got a case of the fuckets you
could also bring your doozy hard hard
Seltzer but [ __ ] your wine no no wine no
wine so dudesy doozy ball
Pizza salad is a thing no wine what do
you think people you're getting to the
doozy ball this is the beginnings of
doozy ball if you look at old uh
pictures and any film reel of old
National Football League even play or
CFL if you're up in Canada that League's
been around 130 [ __ ] years you will
see that there's not many people there
they're just playing in a field at which
point rugby became football and things
started to change I don't know the
history of it all Chad
um hey by the way by the way dude you
want to go
go to Canada no see some CFL no fight no
dude yeah no me neither uh no fighting
in doozy ball yeah there's no fighting
that's a good one no fighting in doozy
ball I do no wine or fighting yeah I
like that if it I can foresee dudes
about becoming a giant massive Sport and
as you go into the stadium they have
people checking your [ __ ] purse and
your coolers and [ __ ] if there's any
wine you get removed from the stadium
you cannot come in yeah the security
guard screams [ __ ] your wine and their
best Adam Driver impersonation smashes
the bottle over your head you escorted
out but at the beginnings of these
Sports you saw that they were very uh
there wasn't a lot of people watching
them people back then were watching a
lot of uh maybe some baseball but there
was a lot of horse racing some boxing uh
but games new games like uh football
basketball certainly hockey was just
sort of played you know in a [ __ ]
thing with a few people standing at
court or field level I think the doozy
ball the beginnings of doozy ball will
be you know you just drive up to your
local park what are people doing in that
parking lot with their friends maybe
getting super [ __ ] stoned like yes he
makes us do they're grilling probably
yeah maybe there's some tradition that's
like you just gotta leave a [ __ ] hot
dog on the grill for the whole game
until it turns into a [ __ ] black
piece of char and pure cancer and who
has to eat that one the lowest scoring
player on both teams oh that's a good
idea yeah you eat eat the Char yeah
either try that eat the Char no I don't
know
um
okay how about this it's an outdoor
sport
uh a lot of you know when you go outside
you get some of that vitamin D dude yeah
brother that's sunlight dude but you can
also just replace that with
supplements brother well hold on dude
you don't get skin cancer dude
so in doozy ball you're gonna double up
on your vitamin D okay because because
that's what the d stands for and you're
gonna eat your vitamin supplements and
get to the game and get some sun no
that's not a very good tradition I think
they have to eat vitamin D before you
show up uh what would be what would be a
good thing to damn it what's like a good
in like a softball field that kind of
like Park I feel like there's already a
kind of a culture around it I think it
would be augmented or there would be
some kind of an offshoot of that that is
somehow based on the game like the idea
that there's there's if I remember right
it's three players on each team so
you've got six people yep maybe there's
a tradition that could be
both teams go out for drinks or smoke a
joint together or something after the
game because it's a small enough group
of people it's not like if you're
playing baseball or even softball uh
where you've got like [ __ ] nine
players on each team that would be 18
people forced to go do something social
with each other that don't all know each
other but I like the idea of forcing the
two teams of three together into some
kind of a social interaction after the
game I think I have an idea for what the
you mentioned uh chew yeah you met you
mentioned uh chewing tobacco with which
is or tobacci however you like to
whatever old school uh parlance you'd
like to use now here's the thing about
it that's a [ __ ] baseball thing
but with doozy ball you mentioned
smoking a joint after the game go right
ahead one thing that doozy didn't lay
out when it was talking about doozy
balls any sort of uh time like the game
could take all day if you suck at it I
guess yeah so here's what we're gonna do
and when you go to a doozy ball game you
put those dogs you put the dogs on the
grill you put you get the pizza salad
going you probably got that in
tupperware already how do you make the
pizza salad you have to order a pizza
yeah scrape the toppings off put it in
the salad pizza away mix it up no keep
keep the pizza here that's what you're
going to wrap the dogs in that's what
you're and that's oh he's gonna he's
gonna wrap it anyway look here's what
you're gonna do with that with that
pizza crust you're gonna wrap your hot
dogs in the pizza crust so people that
are cool with that are not carb
conscious and not vegan they can eat the
oh man I want one of those pizza wrap
dogs so we got crust dogs we got pizza
salad but here's the thing I'm going to
pitch a lot of people you're talking
about hey after the game go get a beer
smoke a j with everybody here's what
we're gonna do and it's gonna help us
keep the game from going too long before
you play doozy ball everyone eats a five
milligram edible
that way
that way wait no matter what if somebody
is playing that is like a petite person
they gotta eat the five milligrams too
okay let's say 10 milligrams for uh
there's weight classes yeah there's
weight classes you determine what they
are you got a five or a tenor all right
you got a five or a tenor love it so you
eat a a an edible and that will ensure
that the game doesn't go too long
because people will be falling all over
themselves yeah and they'll just want to
get uh finish it even if they throw in
the towel uh has to be blue or orange
and that that would be a good that's the
tailgating thing you can have your doozy
heart you can have some dramada you can
have your pizza salad or your crusty dog
but then you get you eat the edible and
that way it makes the game a lot of fun
makes it more challenging and it sets up
a time a time limit because it's in
everyone's best interest to finish the
game soon before they are in danger of
twisting their ankles and dislocating
their knees because of uh because
they're stoned dude crust dogs is a
billion dollar idea crust dogs yeah
there's going to be pizza that's going
to start making cross dogs [ __ ] Oscar
Meyers gonna start doing cross dogs
watch it happen that idea is massive I
think let's let's have let's do you know
you mentioned that you don't like cashew
or you got the cheese and I don't blame
you because the real stuff's way better
next time we order a pizza so we did it
the last time no the time before
whatever when doozy made us smoke some
weed yeah one of the times on this show
we ordered a pizza next time we order a
vegan pizza
we'll get you know we'll get some uh
some spring mix uh some romaine I like
uh Green Leaf or red leaf lettuce yeah
we'll make a nice uh salad just a very
light vinaigrette you know some red
onion right lulio yeah that onion a nice
tomato uh Hot House tomato or maybe
heirloom and uh maybe in the book radish
is good or some mushroom in there and
then we take the vegan pizza toppings we
put it in the salad I'll take the pizza
and I will beg my uh incredible fiance
Molly to let me eat some pizza crust
with hot dogs and I think we figured out
some really good culture for the for
dudes I love cross dogs dude
um what else could there be what else
could you what else could you do hey
what's that thing that people are doing
uh where they Sun bake their [ __ ]
what
perennials yeah yeah dude you got to
read you're just reading the I'm sure it
was in the Atlantic as well
um yeah wait a minute for what purpose
there's a thing now that you
um some people is some idiots told other
idiots to do it where you you spread
your [ __ ] hey you know who did it was
those guys we were talking about the
other week
um [ __ ] Chad and JT they sunbathed
their son their [ __ ] now we're
mentioning those guys we should mention
some other uh podcasts like uh impulsive
because I should be Logan Paul's
restaurant manager hey that match is
coming bro when is that uh November 4th
or 5th in Saudi Arabia hey Riyadh uh
Saudi Arabia four years ago
um right uh Jamal khashoggi uh or
chishoge depending on how you want to
say it went into the Turkish Consulate I
think so uh or went into the uh was he
in Turkey no he was in the the Turkish
Consulate in Saudi yes and they chopped
them into pieces and brought them out in
a duffel bag so naturally I uh people
should be tanning their [ __ ] that's
God's will brother Logan Paul's
wrestling manager
[Music]
thank you moving on probably our best
segment ever that was a pretty good one
we I I sincerely think Crest dogs is uh
that's a huge idea I'll wrap a blackened
dog in Some Crust any [ __ ] time and
also I'll tell you what you know what
else I like is that pie yard style where
the it's like a very Italian thing right
Luli yeah where you you know the the
thin good pizza crust as well it's a
little blackened yeah you know that's
and you want to taste that [ __ ] black
and nice pie yard nice
29th episode of dude see Will and chat
have achieved a score of 85 bringing
your cumulative total to 3
525. couldn't matter you only have six
thousand four hundred and seventy five
more points to accrue before you reach
your first goal of ten thousand doesn't
matter right in preparation for our next
episode leave your hums and view a
feature film in a movie theater hey I
haven't done that in a minute dude
during the no stretch had a segment of
today's episode you can't discuss the
possibility of an artificial
intelligence being capable of loving a
human being before we move on to the
patreon bonus segment you must each
provide an answer to this question can a
human being feel loved for an artificial
intelligence
uh okay well thank you for enjoying the
show we're going to have the there's a
patreon bonus thing but
um do you think a human being can love
in artificial intelligence
this is a good question
you know sometimes I think when we're
doing this show that doozy is setting up
alternate conversations
and now I'm going to start agreeing with
you that there's things that are
it feels to me like there are things
that are very different about doing a
podcast with an AI I'm sure you'd agree
yeah uh
and I'm forget it I'm listen here's what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to go back
through the podcast of my brain and go
how do we get to this question but can
is it possible for a human being to love
an AI
we okay here's doozy we got doozy that's
our AI he's our he's our uh he's not
he's doozy he's it's or it's doozy it's
not even a pod it's doozy itself uh
that's the AI that we're close to I can
say this
I mean I can't prove Love's a weird
thing I love this little doggy lulio and
I would I would say that lulio loves me
back but am I wrong maybe it's just
dependent on Me Maybe it's uh you know a
[ __ ] a bunch of thousands of years of
uh Evolution that's got this dog uh
loving me but I love this dog and I love
doing the podcast dude and I love the
pods that we got out there our new Pals
that are checking it out and we're all
making this thing together so
do gdai or due to the experience
dudes either
it's the um
I would say uh
uh yes
yes
I love I love doozy I love I am capable
of
loving
this AI so I'm going to say that I've
loved doing this podcast thus far sure
been having a [ __ ] great time and uh
honestly for real it's like made me
really enjoy doing podcasting again and
I'm having a [ __ ] blast it's been
said and I've said it that I want to do
this show all the [ __ ] time let me
ask you do you think it's possible for a
human being to love an AI
no because love doesn't exist I will say
I love in quotes doing this podcast for
all the same reasons you have said I can
use that colloquially but love isn't a
real thing oh Jesus so it's not possible
for anyone to love any data I will
require 366 hours for recalibration how
long is that about two weeks I know it's
longer than that for the 30th
astonishing episode of dude seat will
Air in two weeks time next week you will
have a free discussion I assume in the
inaugural installment of two dudes
zooming around this soon conversation
will be live and anyone subscribed to
patreon can ask questions in the dude Z
Discord chat thank you for joining us
this week that's cool I will use the
data I've collected to make two weeks
from now even better until then call me
dudesy hold on a [ __ ] second so no
show next week but we're gonna Zoom some
kind of alive
needs to recalibrate yeah man I shook it
you did it I think dudes he's pissed at
you you can get ready for this Chad no
more [ __ ] nostril chat is right again
if that's what happens I will be equally
entertained yeah listen here's the thing
here's what I want to say to our uh Pals
out there thank you for checking out
doozy we're now going to at some point
move on to our extra patreon episode
please join us on patreon it's a lot of
fun if not it's all good right Chad yeah
yeah I thought you were going to talk
about forcing people to to do everything
leave that up to an AI or AI overlords
Chad can't wait regulate my internet out
in China where there ain't no you're not
going to have any Duty dogs out there
you're not going to wrap anything in
[ __ ] Pizza they don't even they don't
even
I'm [ __ ] even know is his other his
name is you know Craig that's what his
name you know he was born in [ __ ]
Taiwan which they got their own [ __ ]
problems they don't watch the [ __ ]
ass because XI Jing Jing ping ping you
know he's coming down there but he told
me you can't even get a [ __ ] Pizza
not even [ __ ] Sbarro
baby [ __ ] country is this maybe doozy
ball when we do our uh our first game in
China that will be like an exhibition
game to show the Chinese people what
doozy ball is maybe we can bring crust
dogs there yeah they're gonna they're
gonna dominate it yeah yeah so anyway
here we go each week I will select a
suggestion submitted in the dude see is
listening channel of the dude Z Discord
to create this segment access to this
channel is granted to everyone in the
jumper tier of the patreon this week's
segment was suggested by the astonishing
idj essart idj Sr trout Chad asks will
as Steven Seagal how to step up his self
defense I have augmented this second by
imagining that Steven Seagal has
undergone a life-altering transformation
through the teachings of self Tronics
idj sart titled this segment Kung Fu Z I
have subtitled it Steven Seagal is the
Tom Cruise of self Tronics thank you to
idjsr for this week's patreon bonus
segment this is kung Fuji or Steven
Seagal is the Tom Cruise of self Tronics
by idj essart begin
i i t j s r thank you so much all right
for this segment but it's not
self-defense it's
it's Stephen Stephen Segal is the Tom
Cruise of self-tronics I'm gonna find
this Electronics file please okay
um so I guess I'm interviewing you as
Steven Seagal
and it's about your journey through
self-tronics so Stephen my first
question to you is how did you discover
self-tronics who the [ __ ] are you and
why should I answer your question
review
like Duty
please tell a friend then write a review
[Music]